in northwest alabama suspected killer is
on the loose and so is a prison official
who authorities believe helped him
escape
casey white is his name he's being held
on murder charges vicki white is her
name no relation she is lauderdale
county's assistant director of
corrections
janet shamley reports on how a notorious
suspect just got away
casey white should be considered armed
and extremely dangerous that warning
came hours after inmate casey white
escaped he was being held in jail on
capitol murder charges and had been
serving prison time for an earlier crime
spree the 38 year old confessed to the
murder he's charged with in 2020 but
pleaded not guilty by reason of mental
defect
austin williams is the son of white's
alleged murder victim connie ridgeway
somebody really needs to find out how
this happened authorities say it
happened like this at 9 41 friday
morning the county's assistant director
of corrections vicki white left the
detention center alone with inmate white
in direct violation of department policy
requiring a two deputy escort
at the time she said they were headed to
a mental health evaluation at the
courthouse less than five minutes away
the duo never arrived and it's since
been confirmed no such evaluation was
scheduled
by about 11 a.m vicki white's patrol
vehicle was spotted at a local shopping
center by 3 30 p.m a booking officer
reported they couldn't get in touch with
her and that her phone was going
straight to voicemail
at this point where we're
pretty much convinced that that she
assisted the inmate escape
rick singleton is the lauderdale county
sheriff
this comes as a total shock and surprise
singleton said vicki white turned in her
retirement papers the day before she
went missing she'd worked for the
sheriff's office almost 17 years
for cbs mornings i'm janet chameleon